another day gets underway in the heart
of Vienna I meet our tour guide
Christopher timmerman at the gnosh
mocked the city's largest open-air
market you can buy produce from all over
the world here there are plenty of
exotic things to try out like jackfruit
it tastes like a cross between pineapple
and banana then there's fish chocolate
which fortunately doesn't taste like
seafood but Christopher Tim Aman doesn't
come here just for professional reasons
you suggested that we meet at the gnosh
marked what do you especially like here
manfully it's so full of life it's a lot
of fun to walk through here and watch
Vienna waking up sitra seem getting off
this is the second time we've booked a
tour with Christopher he took us around
vienna before in 2005 back then his
family business was one of the first to
offer tours on segways
christopher is meanwhile specialized in
themed tours and we opted for the
motorized Personal Transporter they're
simple to operate to accelerate you lean
forward to break you lean back and to
steer you lean sideways and that's how
we proceed through vienna's streets but
in the long run segways aren't very
comfortable so nowadays christopher
offers tours on the only by special
request he prefers giving tours on foot
or by bicycle Austria's national library
is housed in part of the famous hofburg
palace its history goes back to the
Middle Ages and the collection is one of
the world's largest the majestic baroque
Hall alone holds about two hundred
thousand volumes
what is the National Library mean to you
when do you come here and how do you use
it so equals T that's not predict I must
admit that i use the National Library
mainly online I'm fascinated by the
magazine collection we have all the
newspapers since 1703 digitalized and
online this is a real treasure that's
been opened up to everyone and sad shots
did again if you'd they even took museum
octave we continue through the grand old
city of 1.7 million residents more than
half of Vienna is park or woodland we
recharge our batteries in one of
vienna's oldest districts on franciscana
plots Christopher timmerman loves this
square because of its atmosphere for him
it's like lunching in Italy the second
part of our tour is motorized because
our next destination is not downtown the
Danube island is popular among Viennese
when they want to relax Christopher
always comes here to walk his dog in a
bar by the riverbank we watched the
report we made back in 2005 Tim Aman was
passionate about giving tours even back
then but even the biggest fan of Vienna
gets used to the same old sites this is
constable that's funny you never get
sick of the classic sites but they
become routine it's just like with a
fisherman who takes his boat out onto
the sea every day but the ocean remains
something remarkable Vienna has so many
fascinating spots that it never gets
boring
one of these spots is the donor City
Church built in 2000 it's Vienna's
newest church Christopher comes here
regularly for services he likes the
contrast between the gloomy exterior and
the friendly interior
he's equally fascinated by the cemetery
of the nameless in the 11th district up
until nineteen forty this is where
unidentified bodies were buried today a
nonprofit organization takes care of the
graves and then we head back downtown to
our starting point at the gnosh mocked
the stands are already being
disassembled I hope you had fun and hope
to see you again in Vienna it was
fantastic thanks and chow and that wraps
up my tour Vienna in all its summer
glory